Наше ткацьке виробництво існує вже 12 років, фактично
Все почалося з ідеї —
знайти для жінок у селі постійну зайнятість.
Адже у селі Любимівка мешканці живуть теперішніми проблемами.
Влітку будь-яка жінка знайде гроші
на лікування своєї дитини, відвезти її до лікарні, вирішити свої проблеми
Взимку ж все набагато складніше. Немає чого продати.
Немає фруктів і овочів, нема куди піди на роботу
12 років тому мені було все одно, що робити:
свічки, килими чи мило.
Головне, щоб це була постійна зайнятість і продукт можна було продати.
Я випадково познайомилась зі своїми шведськими партнерами.
Вони поділилися чудовою ідеєю створення килимів
і відновлення скандинавської якості.
Ми вирішили це робити в Україні, а саме в селі Любимівка.
Адже поруч знаходиться старе шведське село Зміївка,
тому це все логічно пов'язано.
Так все почалось.
Зараз у нас постійно працюють 40 людей.
Ми робимо досить гарний продукт,
нам є чим похизуватися.
Беремо участь у міжнародних виставках.
Продаємо килими до 29 країн світу.
Спочатку, ідея використання тканини для ткання килимів
походить з далекого минулого.
Тоді наші бабусі
робили доріжки, або «дранки».
Тобто килими зі старого одягу.
Після війни Йозеф Франк був першим,
серед тих, хто був зацікавлений в розвитку старовинної технології виробництва килимів.
Він не хотів використовувати старий одяг,
а яскраву кольорову тканину
і відходи з текстильного виробництва
для сучасного дизайну.
Проте у 50-60-ті роки
текстильного виробництва в Скандинавії майже не лишилось.
Виробництво переїхало далі,
тому робити килими у Швеції практично немає з чого.
Саме відсутність матеріалу і можливості фарбування в Європі
спричинило пошуки розвитку виробництва туди,
де залишилась робоча сила і матеріал.
Компанія «Svenskt Tenn»,
котра представляє оригінальні тканини Френа і його малюнки,
замовляє у нас килими для своїх інтер'єрів.
Нашими замовниками є найпопулярніші архітектори та дизайнери світу
Якщо ми візьмемо журнал «House and Garden» чи «Architectural Digest»,
то в кожному третьому номері журналу можна знайти посилання на наші килими.
Усі верстати були давно вироблені у Швеції і в Україні.
Деякі зробив наш головний інжинер Олександр.
У цьому берді — пісок і свинець.
Якщо ви спробуєте зрушити його з місця, відчуєте — воно нереально важке
Хоча, на початку цього не було...
Важке бердо допомагає виконувати потужні удари,
щоб килим добре збивався.
Якщо він добре збитий —
це гарантія якості і стійкості...
Перші 3-4 роки ми били вручну.
Пізніше Сашко придумав додати компресор.
Раніше у нас три людини працювали на одному станку.
І всі на рахунок «три» одночасно, як в старі часи, прибивали на себе
Зараз цей процес більш вдосконалений технічно.
У нас є перемикачі.
Верстати теж більш складної побудови, аніж звикли в Україні.
В Україні стандарт — 2-4 педалі.
Наші верстати мають по 6-8 педалей.
Тому ми використовуємо більш різноманітні техніки.
Є різні види продукції.
Це шерсть.
Це наша нова колекція, яка була запропонована цього року.
Вперше ми її показали на виставках у Парижі і Лондоні.
Досить високий попит на неї.
Зараз готуємо нову колекцію килимів.
Це наші вчителі.
Керол Делайла і Барбара.
Барбара керувала ткацьким ательє для «Svenskt Tenn».
Вона була однією з перших,
хто почав комбінувати скандинавські килими.
Фактично, вона була гуру в ткацтві.
Барбара приїжджала двічі до нас,
показувала свої техніки і комбінації.
Нам пощастило дізнатися більше.
У нас є кімната зі зразками
До нас не часто приходять гості,
тому ми не маємо більшої виставочної зали.
Зазвичай, тут зберігаються зразки,
які ми для когось робили,
або вони очікують на відправлення (як приклад).
Компанія DHL напевно дуже задоволена,
що ми працюємо саме тут і, що в нас така кількість замовників.
Три рази на тиждень до нас приходить кур'єр,
який отримує від нас велику пачку конвертів.
Ми розсилаємо зразки до близько 15-16 країн.
В цій кімнаті відбувається дуже важливий процес —
тут килими проходять кінцеву перевірку.
Їх вирівнюють, перевіряють,
роблять закінчення.
Ця робота вимагає не менше зусиль, аніж ткацтво
і не менш важливий за ткацтво
Від того, що дівчата не пропустять жодної ниточки чи стіжка і залежить фінальний результат
Особливість нашого бізнесу полягає в тому, що ми справді ткацьке ательє
Ми не робимо стоку,
тобто ми не робимо килими в магазини, де хтось можливо колись їх придбає
Кожний килим був кимось придуманий, кимось розроблений
Іноді траплялися наші зразки.
Дуже часто клієнти придумують власні комбінації чи дизайни
Не дивлячись на те, що вони виглядають досить просто
Насправді, в кожній роботі прихована чиясь геніальна ідея.
Субтитри - Владислав Цовма.